so understanding people motivation the
the organizational structures
everything is giving me this base to
be a successful program manager welcome
to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel stanford
this one is all about community
meet margaret kesselman co-founder and
ceo of every venture
and program manager at applied materials
margaret is a program manager and
entrepreneur with over 15 years of
project management
sales marketing and consulting
experience she led program development
initiatives and delivered multiple
large-scale programs transforming
businesses and operations
and founded a vr device startup she
holds a master's in sociology
helping to understand peoples and
organizations needs
margaret is leading a large russian
speaking women in tech community
where she is championing their growth
and success margaret l kestelman thank
you for joining me how are you
i'm great thank you for inviting me
michael how are you thank you for coming
so late your time
i i really appreciate it i think one of
the great and
not great things about nokoda is that
both i get to talk to really amazing
people but
you know it's a weird time zones and i
really really appreciate it
uh margaret i'd love to talk about your
journey all the way from berlin
university consider yourself an
anthropologist
to working in the vr space uh being
leading russian speaking communities uh
wherever you are
really and now also in applied materials
so take me back all the way to barlow
university and
why do you consider yourself an
anthropologist
of course and i'll take you even one
step one step
before barlow university i immigrated to
israel when i was 11
from a soviet union so israel was my
first big move
and after it we moved another five times
with my family
um i decided to study sociology and
anthropology
um as a basis of all the social
studies i actually wanted to be a
criminologist and then i changed my mind
really i'm pretty happy that i did
really i'm attracted to
to either side of the law well i prefer
to stay on the right side as well
obviously but uh
yeah it always was um like this dream of
being
able to investigate and uh find out uh
clues and um and and answers to
everything and
um i guess the profession that i choose
for myself
eventually is related to it right i'm a
program manager
and i always need to well also to plan
but
also go back and look what happened how
did we get there and
i enjoy it every a range
tell me a little bit about anthropology
as a study or sociology as a study and
how that
is relevant to the role of a program
manager
of course so sociology
specifically is a study about about
people about society
also part of it is to study about the
organizations
different type of organizations in our
case is the
business organizations uh understanding
people's motivation
some of the sociology also containing or
tied to
psychology right so understanding people
motivation
the the organizational structures
everything is giving me
this base to be a successful program
manager
as an anthropologist what i what i like
to do is first to observe
and then to interact right to to be the
part of this tribe or this
team or this organizational structure
and that's how this center anthropology
is
also tying up into my day-to-day work
well i love that you know i i have a
great window here
in tel aviv where i can watch what
people are doing and i call that people
watching i i'd consider myself an
anthropologist at this point
definitely not it not at the concerning
myself with the same questions that
you're concerning yourself but but i can
definitely see
where the interest about society and
about the behavior of people
stems from now a little bit more about
your your move
your immigration from the soviet union
to israel you get
assimilated into the environment you
continue moving
can you share with me a little bit about
that history because i think that is
something pretty unique that
not a lot of my friends perhaps know
about but but it is a part a
very big part of who we are in israel
sure uh i moved with my parents to
israel when i was 11.
and um we we situated in battiam
and a year into standard with my parents
i decided that i want something
different
and i wanted to go to boarding school
don't ask me why i don't remember the
exact reasons i guess
because of this patient to to study
criminology when i grow up
ride the horse or be in the police force
so i started to look for a program and
it was accepted
i was accepted to um
ki bootsberry uh where i stayed for five
years and graduated
uh uh high school
wow that is so cool how to drive it
many interesting things wait i have to
hear more so you're in kibbutz
you learn to drive a tractor what what
my parents are
far away yes
so it's it's a different program it's
not an alley it's
it's called the riatan or um
so we we used to we had a
school in the kibbutz last two years
they
forced forces to go into
regional school but it was really fun
because
we had a lot of freedom for ourselves
and also we needed to work part of our
week it started from two hours a week
and then it was one day a week so we
only studied for
four days instead of five it's also was
part of the perk
or well maybe today i look at it
differently but then it was really
a cool thing to do and uh
yes so i grew up in um
i consider myself as a cable snake in a
way but that is so so cool i love that
and you you know so this you know the
the russian part of you is something
that that he took with you along the way
right
both with barline university you worked
as a russian sector coordinator
in department of representatives you're
also leading
russian-speaking communities and
empowering um russian speakers also
wherever you are so tell me a little bit
about these communities that you're
leading in
and why do you still go back to those to
those same routes and
why spend that quality time on that
of course to the same rules okay so um
i consider myself as a russian israeli
american right now
and also i freely speak hebrew
i grew up there and lived there for 20
years and i speak sign language
russian is my mother tongue and i read
i read a lot and well now i think i read
more in english than in russian but
still
like israel is my dominant language
probably
and in relating to some aspects of
culture
when i went to barulan university
well i had israeli and i had russian
friends and
somehow some of my russian friends
convinced me to join their in the
student association
and the roles that we could get there
were related to russian sector
because we were in that fraction
representing the russian community
so it happened by itself i also was my
department representative and it wasn't
a russian department
as a minor i studied history so i
represented the history department
so it's not only about russians
here in the us again
somehow most of my friends are
i do have an american and a abc american
chinese friends as well
but the majority is people
like me those are russian-speaking
israelis
um very very cool and one of my closest
friends
she organized a group to
to help women to grow and
i quickly joined it and right now i'm
leading it and dealing with all the
operations
uh hosting the events and the idea was
to see
if there is a real glass roof
or forming woman speaking
one or two other languages just starting
their career from scratch
in this country can achieve
high high roles and become a ceo become
very successful
entrepreneurs and what does that mean i
decided to just say
is the mentorship more peer-to-peer is
it more informative
through sessions how do you actually go
and make make an impact on on people and
helping them on their journey
uh we okay we have over 3 000 members on
our
facebook facebook page so in the
community we have like
many members so we cannot mentor all of
them one-on-one however we do have
different programs there uh we did held
several mentorship sessions
we do have workshops once in a while and
those can be different type of workshops
some of them related to resume
interview some of them were specific for
for a field like a qa workshop
or a digital marketing workshop and
another times we have fireside chat so
we just
i'm sorry we have panel interviews with
successful people from a community
not only russian speakers but in many
cases
they are russian speakers just because
we want to show and to prove to
all the women in our communities that uh
the sky is the limit
and um we also have a linkedin group
where the members can ask for referrals
they can
uh post their questions and many uh
other girls would answer it and try to
promote each other to cheer each other i
love that and
so uh useful uh resources
amazing and margaret it's along with you
know leading this
these communities and and working as a
program manager you're also
deeply involved with virtual reality and
phone interaction
and finally you've been working on this
for for something over three years
uh tell me a little bit about your your
perception behind you know virtual
reality
and phone integration and and how you
actually started
working on this product as a program
manager and as a community leader
okay so i didn't realize first that this
was already three years
since i'm doing that so
i i founded the startup with one of my
previous co-workers we used to work
together ten years ago in zorran
and so the phone applications
and the and the virtual reality
hardwares that we're doing are not
not connected so it's two different uh
two different
products um for the
for the phone application it's uh there
are
two gesture apps uh one of them has a us
patent
uh the other one is in the process
uh and then for for the vr what we what
we are developing
is a vr headband that is uh elevating
and helping with uh motion sickness in
vr
in vr games and um
i want to take it beyond vr i also want
to use it in the
automotive industry to treat the
passenger syndrome
especially in self-driving cars how did
i
get there the idea was of my technical
partner
and for me it was just another exciting
opportunity that i couldn't pass
by uh so we did we created a startup
we we showed our product
in a couple of conferences
i did a pilot on about 100 people
and it's proven to be working
and elevating those those motion
sickness
symptoms so we decided to take it to the
next step
uh we uh cooperated with uh
we have a third partner right now he's
in austin
and uh right how do you actually get to
create you know vr against motion
sickness
your journey you know if i would look
back on the journey fast and i had to
guess what type of thing you would be
working on it wouldn't be
vr and motion sickness it doesn't seem
too much aligned with with the rest of
your journey and i love
understanding these non-linear career
pathways so so tell me a little bit
about
your journey with uh with this company
and how
you know that perhaps complements the
other things that you're doing
okay um maybe i'll start with how it
complements what i'm doing
um i'm well i don't want to say restless
but i'm very energetic personal
uh person and i like to try uh to try
different things
i do have a day job now it's an applied
materials but before i was in a
different sector i
was working for nvidia as a genetic
sequencing company
uh but i live in the silicon valley and
except for volunteering and leading a
group of women
i also needed to try that and have my
own startup and
i used to wear many hats in my previous
roles so
startup was just another way of
expressing myself
and while my my partner is the technical
genius
and working on the product itself also
he led me sometimes to
to put my hands on it but i took
all the other roles and i was driving uh
the marketing i was uh
i was growing our network within us into
the underser conferences
doing the market estimation budget
uh hiring um several uh
several contractors in we have a few now
in russia
to help to help us to grow
so for me it was just learning about
other roles
and so now more about the program
managers role
within applied materials like you
mentioned you had a bunch of different
hats on on the different companies today
you're working with applied materials
and i've always been fascinated by the
program manager's
position i don't believe that i had many
on the show with with this position so
i'd love to
hear a little bit about your
responsibilities we started the show
talking about how it relates back to
anthropology and sociology and studies
of people's needs
so so i know that much so far but but
what really
is your responsibility as a program
manager and what kinds of questions
do you concern yourself with on a
day-to-day basis in a fantastic company
like applied materials
okay so the project or program manager
job from homecom from company to company
it can differ
in my current role
what my team is doing is transitioning
products
to low cost region so you need to have a
specification you need to
talk to a supplier my team specifically
is doing also supplier development
so i have a supplier i am responsible
for
and i need to have i need to receive a
package of
documents or and maybe also a sample
from one side of the globe and
recreate the same in another side of the
globe
uh have sociology or anthropology ties
into it
well uh we work across regions so we
need to deal with different cultures
my suppliers in china and the culture in
china
is not nothing like
israel or u.s
previously i also had a supplier in
korea
all those cultures are different um
their behavior
uh their processes
so here is my anthropological or maybe
sociology background
are coming in and make me to sit there
to learn
to to talk to people that uh locally
in those regions to understand how they
operate
and then try to
either either change their mindsets or
at least to adjust
our processes to that to those mindsets
uh
what my role uh or my job entails is
to uh to create a perfect it's never
perfect but
as much as possible uh project plan and
stick to it
uh well we're many times limited
limited in time by by when we need to
take something from one point
and bring it to to finish at another
point
we are not we are actually uh
tight in the budget however we don't um
really
uh we don't drive the
evp so what is usually
the single biggest challenge that you
would face as a program manager
you know when i when i think of
different positions
i i always try to think okay what is the
biggest you know hurdle that you might
have to overcome
so what would it be for a program
manager
so as a program manager you are
responsible for many for many things you
are responsible for some of the
um for cooperation of the team members
right and for the deliverables
but you're not necessarily managing
those people they're not just
they're not always reporting to you so
you need to convince them many times
and the hardest thing is um if
you do have some authority
but it's not necessarily the the one
that everyone will just salute you and
do exactly what you need and when you
need it
uh and i think it's one of the biggest
challenges is to make sure
to understand a if the people will do
what they do
and when you need it and
with a decent quality uh working
in uh inside of the comp with the uh
people inside the company maybe in
different organizations it may be
challenging but
that is achievable working with
suppliers
is slightly different story right
because you don't really control them
so uh being making people to do what you
need
without fully controlling them i would
say this is
one of the biggest challenges that that
makes a lot of sense and margaret
what do you enjoy most about what you're
doing so if you if you have to
think about what what really gets you
going and you're saying you're
relentless you're saying you're so
energetic
and you're so passionate about whatever
you're doing what what really gets you
excited what is
sort of this greatest common factor
amongst all these things
i can okay few things a i don't like
routine
so for me uh working on different
projects
is fun i every time there is an
opportunity to learn something new
so this is one of the main reasons i
choose this profession
and the other thing is maybe somehow
related to it
um and maybe it's not a good thing to
say as a program manager but i do like
to put off fires
and it's it's every day it's in your
farad
every day you tackle a new problem and
finding a solution to it
it it makes you feel alive and to make
you feel contributing
also is a good program manager i must
say that you need to plan the project in
a way that the fires will never happen
but i think it's idealistic so i never
worked on a project when
everything was great that makes a lot of
sense
margaret thank you for coming and
sharing with me our journey
and we you know we're both at j ventures
and i'm very thankful that
for that community that for helping
people like you and me
and me so thank you very much for
spending your time here
before we leave out to ask you the most
important question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
um learn dare
and explore i love it margaret thank you
very very much
thank you again for for joining me so
late in california i really appreciate
it
and thank you for making a positive
impact around you wherever you are and i
love
i love the integration between your
roots and what you're doing today and
your
perception of routine and relentlessness
and putting out fires and getting
excited by
putting on these different hats and
getting excited by the unknown and
this exploration so thank you very very
much and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you for cosplaying michael and
have a good day in israel